in deutschland haben sich bereits
deutlich mehr als 20.000 menschen mit
dem neuen kroner virus infiziert und
bereits um die 100 sind an cupid 19
verstorben in italien mit rund 55.000
infektionen und mehr als 5000 toten ist
das gesundheitssystem bereits überlastet
und mehrere andere europäische und
außereuropäische länder insbesondere
frankreich spanien der iran und viele
weitere versuchen die ausbreitung des
virus zu verhindern inzwischen stufte
das robert koch institut die gefährdung
für die gesundheit der bevölkerung hier
in deutschland als grundsätzlich hoch
ein
aus diesem grund ist bei uns und in
vielen weiteren ländern das öffentliche
leben stark eingeschränkt und sind
grenzen geschlossen aber wie gefährlich
ist das virus tatsächlich ist das alles
panikmache oder wo liegt die gefahr
klicks zum science fiction hier gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasste nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen wir clixoom
und einfach medizin haben bereits
mehrere videos zum corona virus
produziert und viele menschen fragen
sich zu recht wie gefährlich ist denn
dieses virus viele sind von etwas
unterschiedlichen aussagen der
öffentlichen stellen welches den medien
für wird und auch im internationalen
vergleich schätzen die einzelnen
behörden die gefahr unterschiedlichkeit
außerdem entwickelt sich die lage ja
unglaublich schnell jeden tag kommen
neue informationen hinzu und können die
bewertung ändern gleichzeitig sehen wir
also clixoom und ich immer wieder zwei
gruppen an leuten in den kommentaren die
leider die krankheit falsch einschätzen
und dann auch falsche informationen
verbreiten
auf der einen seite die wir werden alle
sterben es ist der weltuntergang leute
die die lage überdramatisieren und panik
verbreiten auf der anderen seite aber
auch die ist doch überhaupt nicht
schlimm was macht ihr euch alle sorgen
warum wird alles geschlossen leute die
kogit 19 nicht ernst nehmen beides ist
falsch und deshalb soll es heute
detailliert darum gehen warum für wen
und auf welche art und weise das saas
corona virus 2 beziehungsweise co wird
19 wirklich gefährlich ist zentraler
diskussionspunkt ist immer wieder wie
möglich ist denn jetzt eigentlich dieses
videos und die wichtige zahl hierfür ist
die sogenannte letalität im englischen
wird meisterten griff case fidelity raid
kurz tief er verwendet
diese teil beschreibt welcher anteil an
infizierten dann auch an dieser
krankheit gestorben ist also man rechnet
letztendlich wurde durch infizierte das
hört sich jetzt erst mal relativ einfach
an ist es beim corona die usa bin ich
bei der zahl der infizierten haben wir
zum beispiel das problem dass die
höchstwahrscheinlich deutlich höher
liegt als die offiziellen zahlen
verlauten lassen zum beispiel deshalb
weil wir nur sehr begrenzte test
kapazitäten haben und dementsprechend
nicht jeden testen können der mit
atemwegs symptomen in die praxis oder in
die klinik kommt gleichzeitig kann es
eben gut sein dass serie verläufe der
krankheit gar nicht zum arzt gehen und
dementsprechend sich auch gar nicht
testen lassen die genaue zahl der toten
zum beispiel in deutschland kennen wir
aber auch nicht da jetzt noch eine große
anzahl der mit saas corona virus zwei
infizierten noch gar nicht gesund ist
also noch gar nicht durch mit der
krankheit und dementsprechend die
schweren verläufe davon noch sterben
können wie ihr seht beide zahlen sind
mit einer großen unsicherheit behaftet
insbesondere in einem land wie
deutschland wo die erkrankungswelle erst
am anfang steht deshalb lohnt es sich
zahlen von den ländern anzuschauen
insgesamt mehr fälle hatten und b vor
allem mehr abgeschlossene fälle haben
zwei beispiele dafür sind china und
südkorea
bei den zahlen aus china weiß man
aufgrund der informationspolitik des
staates zwar nicht so ganz ob die
stimmen aber die haben wenigstens den
vorteil dass die viele fälle haben viele
durch getestet haben und vor allem auch
viele leute wieder gesund sind wenn man
sich die nationalen zahlen chinas
anschaut hatten die eine cf von etwa 4
prozent dazu muss man aber sagen dass
diese regional sehr unterschiedlich war
in der provinz hubei also in der mit
abstand am stärksten betroffenen region
in der dann auch das gesundheitssystem
überlastet wurde lag dies eva er bei
etwa fünf prozent auch italien mit der
region norditalien lombardei steuert auf
ähnliche wenn nicht sogar höhere zahlen
zu da dort das gesundheitssystem
ebenfalls überlastet ist und die
schweren bis kritischen fälle die ja bis
zu 20 prozent ausmachen können nicht
mehr alle adäquat versorgt werden können
dagegen im rest china ist außerhalb
beilag beziehungsweise liegt die cf er
bei so circa ein prozent und auch
südkorea das mit über 300.000 es bei nur
8,6 1000 infizieren so viele tests
gemacht hat wie fast kein anderes land
steuert so circa auf diese tiefe von 1
prozent oder knapp darunter circa ein
prozent hört sich ja erstmal nicht so
schlimm an oder ist es aber potenziellen
denn da niemand von uns gegen dieses
virus - und wir auch keine impfung
bisher dagegen
bisher muss man sagen wie gesagt geht
man davon aus dass sich zwischen 50 und
70 prozent der bevölkerung damit
infizieren werden das würde für
deutschland bedeuten dass sich hier
zwischen 40 und 60 millionen leute
infizieren von denen dann natürlich ein
gewisser anteil auch schwer bzw kritisch
erkrankt von denen wiederum dann einige
sterben werden eine cd von nur 0,5 oder
ein prozent würde bei diesen zahlen
allein in deutschland mehrere hundert
tausend tode bedeuten auch des cdc die
solchen schutz behörde der usa und damit
eine der führenden weltweit schätzt es
sich in der usa zwischen 160 und 210
millionen leute mit diesem virus
infizieren können und davon dann
letztendlich zwischen 200.000 und 1,7
millionen bietet alleine in der usa
davon sterben könnten man muss aber ganz
klar sagen dass das risiko an saas kopf
zwei schwer oder tödlich zu erkranken
nicht für alle gleich ist ganz im
gegenteil das reich von wirklich
minimalem risiko bei kindern bis hin zu
separaten von 20 25 und noch mehr
prozent bei vor erkrankten rentnern über
80 als junge gesunde personen und mit
jung ist unter 40 und 50 gemeint ist
nach allen bisherigen daten das risiko
für einen tödlichen verlauf sehr gering
aber nicht unwahrscheinlich wichtig ist
aber dass man als mitglied dieser gruppe
noch immer epidemiologisch gesehen als
überträger der krankheit eine große
rolle spielt aber zurück zu diesen 1
prozent oder etwas darunter die man
bisher so etwa hatte wenn das
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet wird
das wenn das gesundheitssystem nicht
überlastet wird ist der knackpunkt denn
wenn das passiert kann die situation
gleich ganz anders aussehen wie gesagt
ingo hahn und jetzt auch in norditalien
bekommt man das problem dass es einfach
nicht genug betten und nicht genug
personal gibt die die rasant ansteigende
zahl an hilfebedürftigen patienten und
patientinnen versorgen kann insbesondere
von den ressourcen und
aufwändige intensivbetten mit warten
sind dort keine mehr frei so dass bei
patienten und patientinnen die eine
solche versorgung brauchen inzwischen
priorisiert werden muss wenn es nur ein
bett einen platz gibt und zwei oder mehr
diesen brauchen muss entschieden werden
wer es bekommt und wer nicht eine
schreckliche entscheidung sowohl für die
opfer als auch für die behandelnden
ärzte und ärzten und pflegenden dieses
furchtbare system heißt riesch hier wird
entschieden wer wie schwer betroffen ist
und aussortiert sprich wer nur leichte
symptome hat wird nicht behandelt
menschen mit mittleren oder schweren
symptomen bei denen aber einen
behandlungserfolg relativ
unproblematisch möglich ist werden
behandelt aber menschen und das ist das
was im moment in italien passiert bei
denen die kobik 19 erkrankungen so
schwer ist dass der erfolg der
behandlung ungewiss ist werden nicht
mehr behandelt und man lässt sich
sterben ohne jegliche behandlung was
dieses thema angeht ist deutschland mit
knapp 500.000 krankenhausbetten
insgesamt und ca 28.000 intensivbetten
im internationalen vergleich relativ gut
aufgestellt jedoch muss man beachten
dass von diesen krankenhausbetten ja
derzeit schon 80 prozent belegt sind mit
allen normalen nicht kitten fällt zwar
kann man zum beispiel durch absagen
aller nicht unbedingt nötigen ps oder zb
durch gewisse organisatorische
umstrukturierung gut kapazitäten und
ressourcen erhöhen aber trotzdem werde
in zukunft dieser akuten krankheiten und
unfälle ausserhalb von kogit 19
einen guten anteil der kleinen haus
betten belegen darüber hinaus wenn die
meisten von euch schon mal vom
ärztemangel oder vor allem vom
pflegemangel gehört hat der ebenfalls
einen limitierenden faktor darstellt
weil man braucht er nicht nur materielle
ressourcen im sinne von einem bett
einbetten platz tat muss gerät
sauerstoff anschluss usw sondern auch
das entsprechende geschulte personal das
sich um die patienten kümmern
deshalb muss in den kommenden wochen und
monaten ein wichtiges wenn ich sogar das
oberste ziel sein die überlassung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern
dabei spielt die infektionsrate eine
große rolle wir haben zu sein außer
kinos und eben bei auch bei uns in
deutschland einen sogenannten
exponentiellen anstieg der infizierten
zahl das sieht so aus jeden tag kommen
mehr neue fälle hinzu als am tag davor
und die zahl der infizierten verdoppelt
sich innerhalb weniger tage
das ist das was wir eigentlich nicht
haben wollten obwohl es anfangs
schleichend beginnt für dieses
exponentielle im weiteren verlauf
ungebremst schnell zu extrem hohen
zahlen in diesem fall infektions und
patientenzahlen die unser
gesundheitssystem akut nicht auffangen
könnte und genau aus diesem grund
bestehen diese hatten einschränkung
keine schule keine kita keine uni keine
spielplätze grenzschließung
ausgangssperren sowie die anweisung
soziale kontakte möglichst
einzuschränken ziehen alle darauf ab
dieses exponentielle wachstum zu stoppen
und die kurve abzuflachen wie gesagt es
geht nicht darum die infektion zu
stoppen das geht gar nicht mehr sondern
die progression stark zu verlangsamen um
weniger patienten und patientinnen
zugleich zu haben so dass das
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet wird
im englischen das haben bestimmt einige
von euch schon gesehen trennte deshalb
zurzeit der hashtag plettendorf deshalb
auch wenn man selbst nicht gefährdet ist
wenn man zb jungen gesund ist beachtet
bitte trotzdem diese regeln und
maßnahmen die nun in kraft treten um
eben unser gesundheitssystem und all
jene zu schützen zur die das virus
selbst eine echte gefahr ist ich
persönlich mache mir zum beispiel auch
keine sorgen sollte ich persönlich
irgendwie kugel 19 bekommen da ich nicht
annähernd zu irgend einer risikogruppe
gehöre aber auch ich habe großeltern und
andere personen in meinem umfeld für die
eine infektion mit dem virus und dann
cupid 19 echt gefährlich sein könnte
ich dagegen gehöre zu den risikogruppen
ich bin etwas älter habe schweres asthma
mir könnte eine infektion mit dem corona
virus echt gefährlich werden weshalb ich
mich nun auch seit einiger zeit schon in
quarantäne befinden aber es gibt da
draußen noch viele weitere wie mich
jeder hat auch großeltern und viele
dieser leute können vielleicht nicht so
eine quarantäne machen wie ihr es
derzeit durch die weshalb die auf eure
mithilfe angewiesen sind deshalb nimmt
die maßnahmen ernst schränkt teure
sozialen kontakte 1 und bleibt up to
date danke corona virusgrippe was ist
gefährlicher unbedingt anklicken
anschauen danach wisst ihr auch dazu
ziemlich gut bescheid abonniert einfach
medizin das geht hier da gibt es noch
mehr hintergrundinformationen zum saas
kopf
bei und jeden tag um 19 uhr einen stream
zu den tagesaktuellen kochen news bis
dann bleibt